hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Jerusalem Fida grand
prix 2019
it's way Everson's an expiry two of
their classical games have ended in a
draw and the first rapid game ended in a
draw so this is the second game of the
rapids where we has the white pieces and
well everything about this game is
interesting it features are really weird
opening a really cool middle game and
most important of all that there's no
end game so a bit of a spoiler there but
I'm sure you're gonna agree that it
doesn't matter and we do have a nice
photo of this matchup here it is even
though it's from the first rapid game
where gear we had the white pieces but
we don't have still a photo from the
second rapid game in the background
there you see the blurry nipple
battling it out with with Boris Gelfand
so that being said let's check out the
game wayy with the white pieces opens
with E 4 we have c5 the Sicilian defense
and here we have Bishop to e2 the
so-called slow variation which well it's
very flexible that goes without saying
but on the other hand it allows the
black pretty much to do whatever black
wants
so we have nice to see six by Giri with
f4 by way and the immediate the d5 so
already black achieves the dream
executed e5 in the Sicilian but it's one
of the one of the well not nicer things
about playing this variation now we have
D 3 and now Geary doesn't want to trade
characters captors and trade queens
instead he goes for g6 just continuous
development now we have Knight to f3
Knight to f6 and now II five pushing the
knight back and here we there is a game
where night 2 g8 was played the night
the g4 is a no move but the Giri goes
for Knight to h5 his 80s he wants the
ribbon over the Knight to g7 and then
TSX to put pressure on f4 and it is
already as of move 6 that we have a
completely new game something that does
not happen very often often especially
in elite chess we have castles by Wei Yi
and Knight back to g7 we have Bishop to
e3 continuing development now d4 an
important move as you want to move the
bishop away
from the defense of the f4 point so
knife the e6 comes with a threat so
Bishop to f2 and the now Knight the e6
putting pressure on f4 so we defense it
and the Bishop to g7 now everything is
ready for Geary to castle we have Knight
B to d2
now after black black advance the pawn
to d4 he weakened d4 in c4 square so
perhaps wife can use that to get a
better central square for his Knight
with castles by black and the now c3
just the challenging black center and
black does the same with a f6
challenging white strong center with eek
a press-on f6e captures on f6 and now
Queen to b3 putting pressure alongside
this diagonal and also making it
somewhat difficult for whites to develop
the light square bishop so we have pink
to h8 immediately unpinning and rook F
to e 1 with b6 now the b-pawn will no
longer be a target and now Bishop to f1
black will probably develop the light
square bishop on this diagonal so white
will probably do the same to counter the
effects of the dark square bishop with D
captures and c3b captures and night to
c7 now now black a giri decides that he
wants to develop the bishop this way
which will come with an attack on the
queen and then the knight can maybe come
to d5 we have rook a to d1 and now comes
the shock to e6 just attacking the Queen
and asking well asking the way do you
perhaps want to capture on e6 and if you
capture on e6 you get nice the a5 that's
the problem you take away the Queen from
the defense of the rook so the Queen
will not be able to stay on this
diagonal the Queen has to move and then
you pick up the rook so after this Queen
to be to move after bishop thesis we
have Queen to be 2 just getting the
Queen out of the way and now Queen to d7
preparing to bring the other look into
the game with d4 and now see captures on
d4 with Knight captures on d4 Knight
captures and Bishop captures and here
Bishop to g4 putting pressure on the
rook here black would really enjoy if
white moves the roof from the default
then black and just completely owned the
D file descriptor e 2 countering
Black's like lights work this up and now
rook 88 and if you look at this position
sorry rook 8e a yeah if you look at this
position it's a it is a complicated
position a lot of pieces on the board
both players still have the bishop pair
and most of all White has to isolate his
bones so the a pawn and the C pawn
however the C pawn although it's not a
very strong pawn it will do wonders
guarding the bishop on d4 so if white
gets to keep the bishop on d4 that
Bishop is just a monster controlling the
entire board so Bishop captures in g4 we
have Queen Catherine g4 and now Knight
to c4 we have nice the d5 by giri and
here comes Queen to F to Knight to d5
it's an excellent square for the knight
but it also comes with the threat of
just knife captures on f4 as the G point
spend so Queen to f2 defending if black
should capture and now rook to d8
getting getting out of the tension here
and now comes Luke the d3 with ideas of
maybe doubling groke on the D file but
also just adding another defender to the
3rd the rank we have looked after I ate
and now comes a very creative move by
way e which starts an avalanche of crazy
ideas Knight to d6 which is just well
asking black what do you wanna do your
rook is under attack and it's under
attack twice so here Gary trades once
with rook captures Queen captures and
now K you cannot capture the night
because it is just meeting to check
their blocks and then this is mate so
you replace King to g8 and now rook
captures and d6 is a threat because
after let's say and well not that but
after the Queen checks now you can block
Bishop f8 because the king guards the
bishop and here comes Knight to e8 and
here is where the magic happens now the
bishop is under attack so if you
eliminate this Bishop then nothing will
be able to oppose a white light/white
dark square Bishop and well it's not
easy to find a move here for black
especially for Geary who is very low on
time so just to point out how many
things can go wrong if you try something
like Bishop to f8 seems like a
reasonable idea
you know white will be unable to capture
your bishop
also you have in mind maybe something
like rule d7 rook e8 to pick up the
night here
but the problem is white has Bishop
captures and b6 seems like weird move
you know
like nothing is happening on the
queenside what's the point of this the
point is if the bishop is captured you
play rook captures on d5 and you've
eliminated all the defenders of the f6
pawn so now you don't really have a move
it's just a loss for black and of course
if you capture then it's a monster for
key the queen king and rook are forked
and there's nothing to do here for black
but there was a move where giri in this
position that giri could have improved
his position it's a hidden move and well
now that I've told you about what all
the you know all the poison lurks in the
position I'm sure you would have found
it by now but its Queen to f5 the point
is that now Yuri maneuvered the Queen
away from the dangerous g4 square so in
the future the knight captors on f6 will
not be capturing the Queen and you don't
lose time doing it because the rook on
d3 is under attack
so once the rook moves then you go
Bishop to f8 and now black is even
better so this is a slight improvement
for gearing the position although it's
unrealistic to say that it was in the
position since it's a rapid game gear it
was very low on time and you have to
play something so here get replayed an
even better move well or so he thought
he played Knight captures on f4 and it
seems reasonable well the the knight
cannot be captured the pawn is pinned
the rook is under attack Knight to h3
also is coming so it's a definitely a
great move but it loses the game so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
why it loses the game while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and figuring out that the knight on d5
was a really important piece because it
was covering the e7 square and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's Queen to e7 when the knight
captured an f4 it lost the control of
the e7 square and now just Queen
captures in g7 is the threat of
checkmate and the giri continued with
Knight to h3 check but just to show you
eliminating the three
a threat of meat by removing the night
it doesn't really help black after
Bishop covers with Bishop to f8 you get
a rookie three now you control the e2
square twice and there's no way to
wiggle out of this one if you go now -
to recheck just King g2 if Knight f4
check now you move back King f2 and now
if Knight h3 check once again King II 1
and here black is really without any
compensation for the force for the you
know sacrificed exchange and after let's
say queen a5 threatening to go for some
queen f to check ideas or maybe queen to
be one to harass the White Queen King
just Queen e6 check exchanges here and
you don't really have compensation yes
you are up upon but a rook is a look so
white white will be winning this game
without a problem
so after Queen to e7 first we discussed
the rook captures and it doesn't work
and now Knight to h3 this is what gear
we played we have Quinta f1 and now
Queen to f1 with check now with idea of
coming to f2 but now King to g2 now
Queen f2 check is just met with King
captures on h3 sorry the Queen can't
even come to f2 so it's not even a
threat forgot about our good friend of
the bishop here and here rook the d7 you
have to guard against mate so once again
pause the video here and try to find the
incredible variation the only line that
wins this for white and well one of the
bigger reasons why I decided to show to
show you this game well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations on
finding this incredible line that
features a temporary Queen sacrifice and
for those who just want to enjoy show
its Knight captures on f6 this comes
with check of course you cannot capture
with the Queen because you lose the
Queen so the shop characters on f6 and
now Queen th check leaving black with
only one move that one move is King to
g7 and now comes the movie had to find
I'm just gonna give you a few more
seconds to spot this one because it you
know from that position it's not an easy
line to find but you know
congratulations to everyone who found it
it's a queen capture son d7 and believe
it or not it was in this position
unmoved 36 that unnies giri resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here if the queen is accepted then
Bishop captures on f6 with check well
king captures and the rook captures on
d7 leaves you with this terrible end
game which is very easily winning you
you have to save the night then
recapture Sunday 7 next you're gonna
capture this point as well and this is
completely winning for white and the
other option is to not accept the Queen
is to just move the King from check but
this this is even worse because Queen
captures now you have to capture the
Queen back now Bishop captures on f6 you
are up a whole rook and again if Knight
g5 just trade down into a young
Gustafson endgame where one player has a
rook and the other player doesn't so
Queen captures and d7 with check very
impressive stuff and well it's just just
one one icer ways to win a game that
I've seen in quite a while in in top
tier chess so yeah with this loss
Anish giri is eliminated from the feeder
grand prix like i said to the classical
games would run then the first rapid
game was drawn and then the second game
was won by wayy so that's it for any
giri and the way he advances to the you
know upper floors of the of the
tournament so i do hope you enjoyed it
and yeah that that's pretty much it i
would like to thank Paul Bunton and Sven
FOIA for contributing to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the feeder Grand Prix 2019
the last leg of it continue to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and of
course whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and do be a part of the
subscribers video thank you all I will
see soon and have an excellent rest of
your day alright perhaps I said that
twice but you know still have an
excellent rest really